dann gucke ich jetzt mal weiter in den
kommentaren versuchten nächsten fragen
hey was geht ab jetzt bekommen bei einem
neuen video
ich hab euch um entsorgung gefahr stellt
mir doch mal ganz viele fragen und ich
hab wirklich mega viele bekommen 400
oder so es war wirklich schwer die
kreativsten beziehungsweise am besten zu
beantwortenden rauszusuchen ich hoffe
ihr seid jetzt nicht allzu enttäuscht
wenn ich eure jetzt nicht beantworten
kann
ansonsten wünsche euch viel spaß mit dem
zweiten fragen und antworten video ihr
habt euch das ja gewünscht
beziehungsweise als erstes mega gut
ankommt und was hier auf jeden fall auch
sagen wollte
da ich auf youtube mit abstand am
meisten follower beziehungsweise
holländer stellt mir doch mal bitte hier
unten in die kommentare ganz viele
fragen für das nächste fragen
beantworten video rein wenn ihr halt
auch mal wollt dass eure fragen
beantworten wir jetzt viel spaß und die
kamera steht soweit wirklichkeit gar
nicht so machen doch kann ich so die
erste frage kommt von lisa und zwar
facti wenn du ein buch bekommt in dem
deine zukunft steht würdest du es lesen
also ehrlich gesagt würde ich das auf
gar keinen fall geben weil ich meine
wenn ich jetzt genau wissen würde wie
zukunft meines lebens aussieht dann ist
das doch mega langweilig dann macht das
leben doch gar keinen spaß mehr wenn man
irgendwie immer weiß was jetzt im
nächsten moment passiert keine ahnung
wie ihr seht aber ich sehe es garantiert
so dass das buch direkt in müll werfen
oder ich will es vielleicht nicht müll
werfen aber zur seite legen so die
nächste frage von lilo oder so was
würdest du tun wenn ein großer fan
zuschauer sah ich immer lieber von dir
dich auf der straße sieht und nicht dann
aber nicht mehr gehen lassen will und
nach deiner nummer fragt damit er mit
ihr schreiben kann
würdest du ihm die geben liebe grüße
ehrlich gesagt ich bin ja ich bin nicht
unsportlich und ich kann auch ab und zu
auch mal schnell weglaufen und dieses
schnelle weglaufen würde in dem fall
dann einfach anwenden weil wenn jemand
so kommt das ist irgendwie mega dreist
und solche person verstehe ich auch
nicht so mag ich auch nicht deswegen
will ich dann schnell weglaufen und da
kommt auch schon zur nächsten frage und
zwar kommt die von michelle denke ich
mal
hat sich dein leben durch youtube
verändert also darf so kann ich
eigentlich nur sagen dass ich mein leben
auf jeden fall verändert hat zwar nicht
so stark aber dennoch ein bisschen man
lernt mega viele leute kennen
mein leben ganz anders mit irgendwelchen
situation umzugehen da man täglich mit
zu reden und damit zu tun hat das heißt
praktisch du kannst viel besser einfach
so plötzlich vor hundert menschen
loslassen als vorher
und ja in gewisser weise hat sich das
leben dadurch halt schon verändert ist
halt ganz normal wenn ich mal sagen wenn
man seit einem jahr aktiv viel denkt was
hochlädt dazu passt doch eigentlich ganz
gut die frage von laura und zwar
faktisch wirst du oft auf der straße
erkannt
ja ich meine dass auch eine sache die
sich ein bisschen durch youtube
verändert hat ich meine ist jetzt sich
allzu krass ich habe etwas mehr als
20.000 abonnenten oder so aber es hat
dennoch so wenn man gegen einer fremden
stadt ist oder etwas größeren stadt sag
ich mal
dann ist es schon ist zwar jetzt nicht
so alltäglich oder so aber keine ahnung
ab und zu wird man halt schon erkannt
und dann kommen irgendwelche weltfremden
leute meistens mädchen auf einen zu und
sagen hey du bist doch dieser eine
können wir vielleicht ein foto machen
oder so und das echt ein richtig geiles
gefühl also wenn ihr mich irgendwo sehen
oder so dann sprechen mich an ich finde
das geil und man freut sich natürlich
auch und so dann kommen wir zu der frage
von anna zwar fragt sie wenn dir jemand
ein angebot macht würdest du lieber mit
einer freundin schluss machen um
millionär zu werden oder mit einer
freundin zusammen bleiben und auf
millionär sein verzichten
da kann ich ganz klar darauf antworten
dass ich mit meiner freunde natürlich
zusammen sein will ich mein dieser satz
geht mit geld kann man sich kein glück
kaufen und ich stimme auf 100 prozent zu
und ja toll hab ich euch eine million
bringt mir nicht wirklich was wenn ich
dann unglücklich bin oder nicht ja die
nächste frage kommt von marina und zwar
fragt sie kannst du mal einen freestyle
rappen
ich nehme einmal eine beatbox auf oder
versuche ich und dann richards war los
und zwar ehrlich beantwortet eure fragen
und die nächste frage die kommt von
hagen wie du willst mir sagen und
zu schauen gibt es keinen haken dann
gucke ich jetzt mal weiter in den
kommentaren versucht die nächsten fragen
ja und nach dieser kleinen rap-einlage
gibt es dann natürlich auf die letzte
frage und das hat jetzt mehrere reihen
kein arbeits aber nicht geplant
und zwar ungefragt sophie willst du wenn
du es bist auch noch youtube videos
machen ungefähr mit 20 bis 30 eigentlich
kann ich darauf nur an bord wenn es mir
bis dahin immer noch spaß macht dann
will ich am liebsten zu lange videos
machen wie ich halt freude daran hab
mein wagen oder mit 140 oder so keine
ahnung auf jeden fall war das eigentlich
die antwort auf die frage ansonsten wenn
ihr bock habt dass ich mit meiner
freundin mal die linke mache das heißt
sie bekommen zum kopfhörer auf und ich
auch da müssen wir halt eher raten was
die andere sagte heeb dem video einfach
mal daumen nach oben würde mich echt
interessiert und freuen wenn ihr dafür
seit sich ansonsten in sachen und wo
alles um in der video beschreibung
checkmate twitter und facebook aus bei
mir habe ich jetzt auch wieder ein
bisschen auf vordermann wort habe ich
auch schon mal gesagt
ansonsten geht es hier auf der linken
seite weiter mit meinem letzten video
das war dinge wie sie mädchen und jungs
waren zwei und hier auf der anderen
seite mit meinem letzten fragen
beantworten video das war der zweite
teil zeigt auf jeden fall weil es mal
aus und wir sehen uns dann am wochenende
wieder haut rein